えっと ではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはあまり大胆な結論が何もなくて
どうしようかなと困っていたんですけど
少々つまらなさはあるかもしれません
[笑い]で テーマは忘れちゃったから出すまで
まああの 報告されているテーマは何でしたっけ
えっと 肉体物質に依存する
依存した科学には限界があるということで
まあそれはちょっとニュアンスを変えてね
財産が我々に楽しみをもたらしてくれるのかというテーマにしたんです
同じことですけどね それでこの Limits of Happiness という
この幸福の制限というのはどういうものかと
これから勉強したいと思います
まあタイトルなんですけど
まあだから人間楽しいということ
楽しみたいでしょうしね
楽しみたいんです 楽しむためには体に
物に依存するし そちらいろいろ制限があるんですね
その制限でどういうものかということなんです
はい えーと まあ同じことを
まあそれは日本語の訳で
まあこれから日本語で喋りますので
だから一般論でいう幸福とは
物や肉体に依存して得られるものなのです
さて 人は依存することでどこまで楽しめるのでしょうかっていう
物に依存して我々どこまで楽しめるのかということです
じゃあこれから本題に入ります
で 幸福と楽しみとは何かと
世間に伺ってみる ということは
俗世間の一般の人々から我々聞いてみると
幸せって何なのかというと
このような答えが出てくると思います
まあ第一に お金が来ると思いますね
お金があれば幸せですよと
まあまあ ちょっとまあまあいい加減入れたもんですけどね
はい まあそれはあまり異論ないと思います
これ第2番目に来るんですよ
この家族 家とかね 住むところとかね
まあそういういい家族ができればとか
なんとかとかね いい家があればとかね
やっぱり第一には金が来ると思います
現代ではね まあそれは時代によって変わりますけどね
で 次に まあそれから出てくるのは
まあいい仲間がいるならばね
人間関係ね 友人たちとかね
楽しい人付き合いできれば
これでまたいいんじゃないかなという幸福感が出てくると思います
で それから人っていうのは
まあそれほど数がないかもしれませんんだけど
知識さえあれば人は幸せではないか
権力さえあればね 幸せではないかなと
まあそこだけではね まあそうかなという疑問があるかもしれませんだけども
我々はやっぱりいろんなことを勉強したいという気持ちがあるんですよ
あれもできればこれもできればというね
まあ幸せだなと 英語も喋れるから幸せだなと
フランス語もペラペラ喋れれば気分いいでしょ
幸せでしょ 別にだからどうということではなくて
我々は一般的に まあやっぱり好きなんですよ
そういうことは あれもこれも勉強できればいいんじゃないかなと
それは子供の頃そう思ってくれればありがたいんですけど
年取ってから思ったってもね
もう遅いんですけど やっぱり子供の時はそれ全然思わないんですね
勉強した方が幸せだなと
だからちょっと時間のズレがありますよ
今の年になってね やっぱり勉強したいなと思ったって
あまり役に立たんかもしれませんですね
で まあ権力っていうのはこの子供にもあるんですよ
谷川は男だったらすごい強い人になりたいとかね
あの 何て言いますか えっと
ウルトラマンになりたいとかね
という気持ちはあるんですよ
だからそれは結局権力の問題なんですね
で まあ一応我々社会人になってからはね
そんなに権力は持てないということはもう分かっているんですけど
でもそれでも その中でもやっぱり課長になりたい
部長になりたいとかね
で 社長になりたいとか思っている人々はいくらでもいますよ
それ 権力欲なんですよ
別に給料さえあれば もう課長にならなくたっていいのに
やっぱり課長になりたいでしょうに
あれは給料がいいんだからというわけじゃないんです
格好つけたいんですよ
俺が偉いと だからまあ
それが権力欲なんですよ
まあ当然権力のみを目指している人々は
幸せは政治にありということで政治に参加するでしょ
それでまあ直接権力をねじってねじろうとする
だから本当に人間の中で権力が欲しいな
人を支配したいなと それこそ自分の立場があってかっこいいなと思っている人々のみ政治に参加する活動は
いわゆる活発的な政治に参加する
で 他の人は一応投票するだけで終わっちゃいますけどね
それで政治に参加して
なんとか議員とか なんとか地方議員とかなんとかなったところで
これでもっと上上行きたくなるんですよ
国会議員になったら まあ副大臣ぐらいでもになりたいなとかねと思ったりはする
何のためかと聞いたってもわからない
ただそれが幸福だと思っているだけの話なんです
だからそれは知識権力というのはそんなもんで
まあとにかくみんな第一に来ると思ってますけど
本当は一番下に来るんですよ
健康 何でしたか 健康ということ
そのような順に回答されるでしょうと
世間から見れば大体健康でいられれば幸せだなと言うでしょう
今は大体日本の社会では健康第一と思ってますけど
あれは順番違うんですよ
本当は健康はすごく後回しに来るんですよ
なぜかというと 健康第一と思うのは中年ぐらいになってくるとかね
あっちこっち壊れていくとやっぱり健康だと思うのであって
若い頃は全然気にしない
そんなことは だからまあ健康がなくなると
やっぱりこれあった方がいいと思うんですから
これは順番的には最後だと思います
これは世間から世間の皆様から聞いたっても同じことで
それですから いろいろ異論があるかもしれません
皆様方から個人的に聞けば
私ならこれは 1 にするぞとか
それはあるかもしれません
まああくまでも個人の考え方ですからね
必ずしも全ての人間がこういう風に思っているわけじゃないんです
まあいろいろあります
一応一般的にはこんな順番にはなると思います
それでまた そういうことを考えるとどうなるかというと
幸福はほとんどもののせいにしてるんですよ
お金あれば幸せよと言った途端
お金のせいにしてるでしょ
気が合う相手と結婚できれば
これ幸せだなと言っちゃうと
この誰かのせいにしてるんですよ
あるいはもう気分のいいところで
空気の綺麗なところで
もう 1軒家あれば幸せだなと思っちゃうと
またその家のせいにしてるんですよ
だから この今まで世間から聞く幸福論って何なのかというと
全部もののせいにしてるんですよ
それはすごく特別なこと
それをよく理解してほしいんですね
我々は幸せでないのは私のせいじゃなくて
もののせいだと思っていることの
あなたのせいで私は不幸だよということなんですよ
世間のせいにしているんです
だから 金があれば幸せだなと思うことは
金っていうのは世間のものだからね
それが私にないんだから不幸だよと
いうことなんです だから
俗世間から聞けば このもののせいにするということは特別特色なんです
それで自分にある順番よりもない順で言うんですよ
これなんか何言ってるかわからないでしょ
説明すればもしかするとわかるかもしれません
人に聞けば幸せって何なのかというと
例えば自分にあるものあるでしょ
まあそれなりの仕事もあるし
まあ何とかアパートでも住むところもあるしね
まあお母さんお父さんとも仲良くしているし
まあ家族もそれほど問題はないとかね
それは言わんですよ あるものは言わないんです
ないものから始めるんです
[笑い]もっと給料は 5万ぐらいでも上げてもらえば幸せだなとかね
それないものでしょ 子供は早く大学出てもう社会人になってくれればもうありがたいなとか
いう風に自分にないもの順番で言うんですよ
幸せを あれって何でしょうかね
あるもの順番では言わない
そういう意味なんです
ですから それは普通でしょ
幸せって何なのかと 私には一応若い頃勉強もできましたし
それで幸せで それなりに仕事もあるし
日本の経済状態は結構良くはないんだけど
なんとか安定した収入は今頃は得ているし
家族も別に問題はないし
だから幸せ そういうのがあれば幸せじゃないかなというふうに言わないんです
でしょ ないもので もうちょっと痩せた方が幸せ
もうちょっとここら辺の肉がね
ちょっと細くなった方がねという
そういうようなことですよ
だから幸せは何なのかと世間に聞けばない順番で言うんです
はい まあ例えば説明は書いてましたけど
例えば家族がいるなら家を欲しいという
例えば幸せな家族がいる
お子さんもいて 子供 2人ぐらいいるし
みんなもう仲良くすごく楽しくもう生活している
でも 仮屋借家というんですか
もうもうところに住んでいて
そうするともうちょっと自分の家があればいいなとかね
と思っちゃう だからその人の幸せって何なのかといえば
やっぱり自分で住めるちょっと大きい家でもあればね
ちょっとした庭もありまして
子供に遊ぶ砂場でも作れるものあれば幸せだなと言うんです
だから その場合もないことを先に言うんですね
実際何が楽しいのかとは知りません
この我々はあれこれやと言うんだけど
結局楽しみって何なのかと
誰も勉強しないんですよ
ただまあ 尻に火がついたような感じで
もうみんなやってるから
あれもやって これもやりましょう
あれも欲しい これも欲しいって
だったら幸せだなという風に走り回ってるんであって
別にこれが幸せという考え方は持ってないんです
だからもののせいにしてるんです
幸福に 楽しみについて明確な理解はない
幸福って何なのか 楽しみって何なのかという
この明確な定義して得た知識がないんです
これすごい必要なんですよ
一人一人楽しになくちゃあかんでしょうに
一人一人の人間が幸せにならなくてはいけないでしょうに
仏教から見れば 世間から見れば
まあ一部だけ人間が幸せになればいいかもしれませんだけど
仏教はそういう立場を取らないんですよ
すべての生命が幸せにならなくてはいけないんだと
うちの宗教は信仰してる人だけ幸せという話は仏教でないんです
その信仰はどうであろうとも
生きているものだったら幸福であってほしいと
幸せでいてほしいというのは仏教の理論なんです
だから仏教はすごい真剣にそれを問題にするんですよ
個人個人が幸せにならなくてはならないのに
その個人が幸せって何なのかという定義は持ってない
理解持ってない 明晰じゃない
これではうまくいかないんですよ
例えば皆様はどこかで仕事をすると
仕事をしたら何かそれなりの給料というか
何か賃金もらうでしょ
その場合は何でもいいんだからくださいと言いますかね
ああそうですかと言ってゴミ箱くれたらどうしますかね
例えばどこかのね あのファーストフードでバイトやった若者がね
もう遠慮して まあもうまあ何でもいいんだから店長くださいと言うと
大量の生ゴミ袋とかあるで
では君はこれ持ってきなさいと
そんなのはありえないではなくて
おかしいでしょうし だからこれぐらいお金ちょうだいということでしょうに
はっきり具体的にしないと
あれはお金でなくてもいいんですよ
例えば ある若者が結構良いギターがある家にある
それは結構お金値段かかるもので
でもその家の人はもうほとんどそれ使ってはない
しかし大事にしている
これがこの若者にはもう欲しいんだけど
お金がないんですね 店で買うために
だからくれって言うのもちょっとできないし
それでその人に何かお手伝いしてあげたりとかね
もう庭のもう手入れとか何とかしてあげたりとか
ペンキを塗り塗り替えてあげたりとか
なんとかして では君の仕事にってお金がなくて
もしあれ 今使ってないんだから
ギターでもくれればありがたいなとか言っちゃうと
それで十分ですか？と
持っていけって言うでしょうに
だからそれその若者が楽しいでしょうに
だから具体的にしないと
幸せは成り立たないんですよ
そういうわけで 仏教はね
各人が幸せにならなくちゃいけない
ですからはっきりしろよと
何が幸せかと はっきりしなきゃとんでもないことになるんだよっていうのを言うんですよ
その説明は次に来ると思いますけど
幸福を得ようと生きているのに
その幸福とは何かと明確に知らない
人間は生きる目的といっても
ただ本当は幸福になりたい
もっと楽しみたいという単純な考え方なんです
誰一人私はもうとにかく死後天国に生まれ変わりたいと思っている人がバカがいないんです
言ってる人はいますけど
あれは嘘です 本気じゃないんです
私は死後極楽道に生まれてから
そのために生きているんだとかね
宗教ではごちゃごちゃ言ってますけど
その宗教を教えている神父さん
牧師さんでも真面目に信じていないし
もう信仰している人々もそんなに真剣
真面目に思ってないんです
いくらかといえば イスラム教だったらすごい脅しが多いんだから
もう結構真剣だと思いますけど
死んだら地獄のやつら大変やと
そんなに真面目じゃないんです
麻原のケースがあった時は
色々マスコミやら色んなみんな行くでしょ
そちらに 神 神 神 狂信者とか
そこで向こうの若者 すごい凶暴で攻撃するんですね
入るなよ これじゃ入るなよとか
とかね そこでみんなよく言うことは
お前ら地獄に落ちるぞとかね
それ聞いてすごく楽しかったんです
なぜかというと あの連中
人々があまりにもマインドコントロールされちゃって
脅され 脅かされて この地獄に落ちるぞとかなんとか
それをとんでもないところだとものすごく脅されてるんです
だから人が死んだら そちらだけは絶対行くべきところな
行ったら終わりやと あの何一つも道徳のひとかけらもわからない麻原にもうマインドコントロールされちゃって
だからそれがマスコミに言うんで
マスコミアジビって何ってわからないですからね
脅しには何にもならない
だから面白いことはそういうところなんです
同じ同士で脅したら怖いんですけど
アジビって何？ってわからないでしょ
こんなことであんたアジビに落ちるそう
あ そう って それは だからそういう脅し
何の意味もないんですよ
ですからこの私は言いたいのは
人間っていうのは結局は死んでから地獄に落ちたいと思ってないし
天国に行きたいと思ってないんですよ
正直なところ それは仏教とも変わりはないんですよ
仏教との人々は 我々と我々日本人と違いますよとか
そんなことはないんです
所詮人間だからね そんな大胆に考えてないんです
武器は当然あることはあるんだけど
そんなに神経質になってということも言ってないんです
すごい気楽におおらかに生きることを教えてるんだからね
だからそんな真剣に死んだら天国に行くとは考えてない
我々は何考えてるかというと
ちょっと楽しみたいんでしょ
せっかく生きてるんだから
ちょっと楽しくニコニコと笑って生活したい
それだけの話でしょ だから正直になってほしいんですよ
それ 仏教的な立場で言えばね
我々人間が余計なことはなくて
ちょっと正直になった方がやりやすいんです
この人生は 例えば私にももういろいろ天国の話やらね
もうもう散々勉強してるんだから
言えないわけないんですけど
こういうこういう徳を積んだらこういう風になるんだぞと
こんな罪を犯したらこういうことになるんだぞとかね
もうかなりもうド派手に言えますよ
でもそんなこと言っちゃうと
ちょっとすごいストレスかかっちゃうし
で 日々の人生の楽しみもちょっとそれにはもう立ち塞わる可能性もあるし
ですから 一般的な人間論で仏教を理解した方がやりやすい
それで人間っていうのは
そんな大胆なことを考えてない
ただ楽しく生きていきたいという
すごい軽い希望で生きてるんです
それが悪いわけじゃないんですよ
すごい軽い気持ちで生きている
すごくいいことなんですけど
問題はその楽しみって何なのかをわかってないところなんです
それが問題なんです だから私から言えば
問題は 2つあります みんな大胆なこと
観念的なことを言い過ぎ
ガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャって
天国はあれやこれやとかね
だってなんでテロがある？自爆テロがあるというと
あまりにも天国 あなた方には天国に特別なところあるんだぞとか
もう仏教のことを全く知らない人々を暗示かけるでしょうに
だからコーランなんかちょっとちょっと斜めに見て読んでみると
テロやってる人々は必ずしも天国に
特別な神様の側に 特別な場所に生まれ変わるとは書いてないんです
まあジハドという言葉は書いてますけど
あれは自分との闘いなんです
自分の内なる悪魔との闘いなんです
だからイスラム教は大嫌い
私さえもコーランにそう書いてるってことを知ってるのに
イスラム教教えこそ絶対的真理だと思ってる人々は
可哀想にいろんな犯罪者に精神異常者にマインドコントロールされるんですね
だから自爆テロやったりはする
だから そういう人々にとっても
やっぱり本当にこの そういうことは困るんですよ
世の中で だからイスラムであろうが
キリスト教であろうが
仏教であろうが もう無宗教の人であろうか
まあ楽しく楽しく生きて生きてみましょうと思っちゃうと
みんな仲良くいられるでしょうに
怖くないでしょうに 人がどんな信仰したっても
今もそれできないんで怖いんですね
別な宗教を 2つ信仰してる二人があったら
何するかわからないので
互いに あんなのは観念的な妄想の結果であって
もっと具体的で とにかくどうでもいいんだから
天国は あるんだったら君行きなさいよと
しかし 我々は仲良く楽しくお互いに協力し合って生活しましょうよと
それでイスラムの友達がいた
じゃあ君は亡くなったらもう永遠の天国に行く
俺はしょうがないんだから
永遠の地獄に行く いいんじゃないんですか
それで しかし この人間として生きている間では
互いに仲良くしましょうよと
だからブッダのメッセージはそういうメッセージなんです
こんな形而学的な得体の知れないことっていうのはね
まあちょっと置いておいて
一休みにして もっと具体的に人生見てほしい
だからそのポイントで見ると
スカカーマニブータニという人々っていうのは
いつでも幸福をまあ探し求めているんだと
なのに他人をいじめるんだと
それだったら自分の幸福もなくなるんだよと
だから今世の中で起きていることをそのまま言葉で教えているんです
スカカーマニブータニヨーダンレーナヴィヒンサアットノスカメーサーノペッチャスオナラバテースカン
幸福になりたいと生きているこの生き物たちは
同じ他の他の生命をいじめたり
殺したり 迷惑をかけたりするんだよと
なぜそんなことをするのかというと
自分の幸福のためであると
でも得るわけないんだよと
この 14歳  15歳のね
可愛い若い子供たちがもう体に爆弾つけてドーンと爆発するでしょう
だからその連中は幸福になりたいと思ってそんなこと
幸福になってるんですかね
なってないでしょうに
だからパレスチナの人々はちょっと何かイスラエル人をいじったところで
向こうはヘリコプターで来て
あっちこっちからもうやりたい放題
ロケット弾で撃ちまくったりするでしょうに
何人死ぬかわからないでしょうに
だからそれでパレスチナ人がすごい幸せで平和で安穏で生きてるかというと
そうじゃないんです ものすごく怯えて
武器だらけの中に隠れて
金と武器と暴力と それで隠れて怯えて生活しているんです
だからユダヤ人も何やってるのかと
知恵の人々がないのかと
と聞きたいんですけど
だから選民だと選ばれた人間だと言いながらやっていることはもう
もう最低の人間がやっていることなんですね
自分たちがすごく頭しっかりしているならば
もうちょっとしっかり行動してすればいいのに
だから人間っていうのはこの幸福
何なのかとわからないんだから
世界地球上で危うく状態なんです
危険な状態なんですね
幸福になるところが生きていられない状態なんです
だから そういうことは
遠い昔 お釈迦様は真理としてもう説かれているんですよ
だから私はあえて現代人に仏教
ブッダの教え あの調合しなくてもいいんです
そのまま言えばすごい
あ なるほどとわかる現代的な教えなんです
だからずっとお釈迦様は言うんです
人は生命がずっと幸福
楽しみを探し求めているんだと
しかし それが何だとわかってないんだから
楽しみでないものは楽しみだと勘違いするんだと
幸福でないものは幸福だと勘違いしているんだと
だから苦労しかないんだよと
ということで で 次の行に来ます
ポイントに 目的は定かではないので
同時に生き方も曖昧 中途半端ですよ
我々は生きる目的は定かに定めてないでしょう
わかってない この楽しむために生きているんだと
せっかく生きているんだから
楽しく生きていきたいという単純な人間だと自分が
これ認めたくないでしょ
結局は どこかで認めたくない
自分がこの単純素朴な人間じゃないんだと言いたくなる
言いたい気持ちがあるんです
あれがとっても危険ですよ
この見え張ることころは
人間というのは本当はものすごい単純で
もう単細胞と言ってもいいんです
もう もうどうしたことない
ほんのちょっとちゃぷちゃぷと楽しくて生きていきたいだけなんです
だからそれをはっきりしないで
なんかもういろんなことをやってるんだから
誰の人生も曖昧でしょうし
中途半端でしょうし だから勉強したっても中途半端
何かやったっても 何でも中途半端で曖昧で
何一つうまくいってないんです
で なぜかというと 何のために生きているのかという
これが単純であるということがわかってないんです
はい 様々な混乱 葛藤が生じる
それによっていろいろ混乱
葛藤が生まれるんですよ
だから金 幸せや子供がいれば幸せやとかね
もう随分曖昧中途半端なことを言う
家があれば幸せだとかね
5キロ痩せれば最高に幸せだとかね
で シワがなくなったらこれほどありがたいことはないんだとかね
まあ何何か言うんですよ
何言うかもわからない
そういういい加減中途半端なことを言ったりして
それに戦ったりすると
それであらゆる混乱が生まれる
例えば 若い女の子たちが恋し始めちゃうと一生懸命ダイエットする
で 相手により気に入られるようにとかね
そこでもう当然若い連中っていうのは
そっちを好きになったり
触れたり 触れたり 振ったり
いろいろでしょうね そんなのは年取ってきてみれば何のこともないんですけど
1年以内に大体 4人と仲良くして
また 4人にももう振られてしまったとかね
そんなのはまあ若い人の場合はどうせあることですけど
その本音にしてみればそう簡単じゃないんです
問題は一人の友達ができたら
もうそれこそ世界一ものやって思っちゃうでしょうね
それで振られちゃうとものすごい悲しくなっちゃうでしょうね
だからその場合は女の子が一生懸命ダイエットする
これダイエットするんだからといって
相手に気に入られるかとかわからないでしょうに
もう苦労してダイエットもしたのに
もう 3ヶ月間でもう喧嘩して別れる
だってダイエットするともうご飯食べてないんだから
結構気が立ってるでしょうね
だからちょっとしたことで気が立ってゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ言っちゃうと
まあもう男はもう怒って帰ったりする
男も性格が悪いし お母さんにももうもうマザコンだからもうもう男らしくないでしょうに
だから何か厳しく言われた経験ないんです
何か言われると言い返す経験は全くないんです
落ち込んでお母ちゃんとお母ちゃんのところに走るんだから
怒られちゃったんだよとかね
28 になっても言うんです
それは だからまあ女は女になってないし
女っていうのは子供産んだらすごい凶暴な母親にならなきゃダメでしょうに
なんだこれっていう状態で男は男になってないし
まあそれは私の今日の問題ではないんですけど
だからただもう混乱 葛藤生まれるんですよ
ダイエットしたんだからといって
相手に振られるとどうするのかと
あるいは逆に男がそれを知ったら
やっぱりこれが責任重い
多いんだと 自分のためにそこまでやっちゃった
これやばいと思う時もありますよ
軽々く仲良く付き合えばいいのに
そこまでやるんだったら
もうこれからこの人と一緒になるとどうなるかわからないと
やばいというふうにもこともあるし
だから人生の中っていうのは
混乱 葛藤っていうのはいくらでもある
今ケースで出したのは若い人々ですけど
まあこれはもう誰にでも年取るまであるんですね
なんでそうやって我々は混乱の中で
葛藤の中で生きてるのかというと
この根本的にこの目的は定かではないんだからなんです
単純に楽しく生きてみましょうということでね
すごいシンプル 単純に楽しいんだったら
若い人が誰か見つけたところで
それですぐ進むんですよ
こちらも気楽に向こうも気楽で
君は気楽でいいやということで
一生やりましょうということになるんですよ
それが全然出てこない
皆様仕事をなさってるでしょうに
それ気楽にやらないでしょ
だからもう頭の上を見てみると
髪の毛がなくなっている
落ちているんだから もうあまりにストレスたまっちゃったりして
だからもういろいろ大変なことになるんですよ
気楽に生きるということができなくなっているのは
我々は余計な大げさなことを考えているからなんです
でも その思考は明確じゃない
金があったら幸せやとかね
家があったら幸せ 課長になったら幸せやという
もうどうにもならないことを言ってるんだから
はい たとえ幸福になっても
人生は成功したという実感はあまりない
まあたまたままあ なんて言いますか
幸福になる場合もありますよ
それなりにうまくいって
でも例えばもう家族に問題もなく
仕事にも問題なく まあそれこれという
そんなに病気もなく まあ生きていると
私は成功しましたと言えない
つまらなくなっちゃうんです
それでも会社も仕事も終わってから家でまあうろうろして死んでしまうだけ
何も問題なかった人生の場合でも
だから何も問題が起きなかったっていうことは
本当に言えば幸せなんです
学校でもそんなトラブルがなかったと
会社でもトラブルなかったと
家庭でもトラブルはなかったと
子育てもトラブルはなかった
それぞれうまくうまくというか
それなりに流れていきましたと
年取ったところで まあ別に人生って何やっていたっても
まあなんかつまらないんですよ
だから人生成功しましたという実感は人間にないんです
うまくいっても はい それで一つの
それで問題点 世間論の問題点があります
一つの楽しみを得ると別なものがなくなるというポイントがあります
なんか一つの楽しみを得るために
自分好きな何かを失わないと得られないということもあるでしょ
例えば二股かけちゃうとかなり危険でしょうね
これが安全な状態に戻そうというともう二人も好きっていうこと
二人も自分にとっては好きだからでしょうね
安定したければ やっぱり一つ捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこの結婚間近になってくると
どんな女性もえらい不安定になるんで
精神的に あれって何でしょうかと
自分はもう早くも結婚したい
早くも結婚したいしたいという気持ちで
必死で男を探して探して
誰か何とかもうもう捕まって
それでまあどんどん話を進んで
もう仲良くなって 結婚するところまで行ってるんですね
そこで結婚を決めたところでまた不安になる
だから 何年前からその目的でこの計画でいったんだから
今更別に不安感じる必要ないんですけど
結婚間近になると大体もうなんか分からないんだけど
もう女性っていうのはすごい不安になるんです
それ何かというと この人は別に悪いと思っているわけじゃなくて
これで大丈夫かなとかね
と思っちゃうんですよ
もう一つ これからも奥さんになるでしょ
今まで大きい世界ですごいみんなに可愛がってもらって楽しかったんだけど
それ全部カットしなきゃいけないんです
全部カットして家の中に閉じ込められてしまうんです
それでスーパーと家の間で人生になっちゃうんです
だから結婚は嫌やって
それでもね 結婚しないとまた人生は不安でしょうし
だから結局は結婚して安定して生きていきたいなという安定感
安らぎ感を得ると同時に
何か他の楽しみを捨てなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで なんとかなっとくいかなくなっちゃうんです
はい また楽しい新しい要求が生じる
せっかく幸せになったのに
それからまた次にこれ
次にこれとどうしても新しいものが生まれてくるんですよ
これは決して避けられないんです
[笑い]何か頑張って幸せになった時点で
それからそれに基づいて新しいものはもういくつか現れてくる
要求が まあ若かれそれで言えば
結婚したらもう子供が欲しいということになってしまうんですね
だから子供を産みたくないなと思っている人にはその問題ないかというと
そういうのはないんですよ
誰にでも一つ獲得するともう一つ出てくるのです
だから この世間での幸福にはその問題点があります
はい それで我々は大体どんな態度をとるかというと
何でも良いから獲得しよう
貯まっておこうという生き方になっちゃうんです
だからこの物に依存して幸福ですから
とにかくもう何でもいいんだから
もうもうわからないんだから
もしかすると後で必要になるかもしれませんということで
あれこれやと もう個人個人で物を獲得しようとする
貯まっておこうとする
現代人間の生き方はそれなんですよ
物は収集するんだけど
あなたにそれが必要かというと
もうそんな余裕がないんです
まあとりあえず貯まっておきますと
とりあえず獲得しますと
まあ店に行ったら衝動買いするような感じなんです
安いんだからとにかくいっぱい買っておきますと
それで後で捨てますけどね
それでもったいないしね
それも気にしないんですよ
だから皆様の家でも調べてみれば
どれほど溜まったものがあるのかというと
一生一回も使ったことないものはいくらでもあるでしょう
でもこれ誰にもあげませんし
もうもし空き巣に入ってそれを持っていかれたらすぐ訴えるまでことまでするんだから
良かったと思わないんですよ
使わないものを全部持っていかれたんだから
これで清々しましたと
そうは思わないんですね
大体使うものは持っていかないんですよ
フライパンとか 持っていかない
大丈夫です ほとんど基本的に使わないものなんです
泥棒が 一度も聞いたことがない
家の冷蔵庫を持って行ったとか
テレビを運んだとか だから開けてもなかったブランドのカバン持って行かれたとか
それは 二十五万でしたとかね
だから損害はこれこれぐらいと
だからそれでいいんじゃないかと私は思いますけど
使ってもないんだから
だって同じルイヴィトンのカバンでも二
三回使っちゃうと泥棒持っていかないんで
それは 本人縛ってるんだから
値打ちがないんです だから泥棒入ってもそんなに損はないんですけど
やっぱり私たちはね やっぱり獲得しようということで必死になっているんだから
それはまあ問題にする
それはまあ今個人的なことを言いましたけど
世界的に見ても いくらあっても
例えばアメリカのこの石油商売をやっている人々は
どれほどお金あるのかとね
考えてみれば なのに あの貧しい国々まで奪ったりして
もうとにかく それでもそれでもということでもう財産を奪い取る
何のためかと 人殺しまでして
生きてるのも個人が人間でしょうね
食べるものも決まってるし
食べる量も決まってるし
もう楽しむ量も全部決まってるのに
だから余計な苦しみを
だからそれで自然破壊にもなるでしょうし
貧富の差がどんどん出てくるでしょうし
もう切りがないんです
問題は はい 次に行きます
楽しんで生きるべきところ
物の奴隷になってしまう
それで収集する 収集する
溜まっていく 溜まっていくことによって物の奴隷なんですよ
我々は自分の人生を物に合わせるんですよ
本当にそれがおかしい
服に体を合わせるという生き方をしているんです
椅子に体を合わせる生き方でしょ
だから今我々の生き方っていうのは
いつでもこの品物に自分を合わせて生きているんです
自由じゃないんです どんな人間にもこうやってこの変な考え方だから
こうやって奴隷になっています
じゃあ次に行きます それで一つポイント終わります
だから第二章に入ります
これは世論 世間の幸福感についての話なんですね
それで第二番目 楽しみはどのように生まれるのでしょうか
という楽しみのメカニズムを理解する必要があるのですと
だからそういうことを
だから楽しみは理解してないんだから
もう全然楽しみ 楽しみない世界を我々は作っているんです
だからお釈迦様は生きることはドッカ苦しみだとおっしゃってますけど
これはもう我々のせいなんです
私たちはそういう世界を作っているんです
ですから 楽しみを理解した方がいいんです
はい それはタイトルで
それから「楽しいのは自分です」というテーマがあるんです
これよく理解した方がいいんです
楽しいのは自分だよと
カバンじゃないんだよと
で 花は美しいではなく
花を見るあなたがそれを楽しんで美しいと思うのです
それは覚えておいた方がいいんですよ
なんとかこの私が書いた文章だから
全然シャレがないんですけど
名言として覚えた方がいいんです
花は美しいんじゃないんです
それ見て楽しむ 気分が良くなった私が
花が美しいというだけの話なんです
美しいと思うということ
だから本当は花が美しいという文章は嘘です
正しいのは自分が楽しんだということなんです
楽しかったっていうことが正しい実感で
それがそう言わず 花は美しいと歌まで書く
だから無茶苦茶なんですよ
一応その意味はわかるでしょう
単純に書いたのはわかってもらいたいんです
覚えてもらいたいんです
例えば女の人見て あんた本当にすごい美人できれいだなと言っても
その女の人は美人ということは言えないんですよ
ではなくて その女の人を見たこの男がすごく喜びを感じたんですよ
それを君が綺麗やというふうな表現をするんです
そこら辺でちょっともう理解の問題が起こるんですよ
そうすると その人も自分が本当に綺麗と勘違いするんです
それで勘違いして 別なところでその気分で振り回るでしょうね
そちらでいろんなことを言われると
もう精神的に混乱するんです
なんであなた方はとかね
だからお互い様 正しく理解すれば
この男は私が見るとえらい気分がいいみたい
だから選べるんだったら
その仲良くするんだったら
それぐらいの価値観がある連中の中にいた方が安心だと思った方がいいのに
別なところに行っちゃうんです
自分の目で見てかっこいいと思う男のところに行くんです
それで自分の目で見て
この男たちがかっこいいと思ったっても
その男たちの目から見れば別かもしれませんでしょ
そこで問題が起こるんです
はい 同じ花を見た別な人がそれを楽しめなかったなら
なんて美しいと ちょっと抜けてます
思わないのです だから上の例の反対の言葉なんですよ
理解するために書いたんです
例えば花 1本があって
私が見て ああ綺麗な花だなと言うでしょうね
それで私が言語能力ないんだから
この花がとても美しいと言う
しかし 私の友達もこちらにいて
その人に見たらべーっとして楽しくないんだ
その花は だからその人がなんて美しい花でしょうとは言わないんです
だから私は言いたいのは
花は美しいではありませんと
はい で だから楽しいのは自分ですというポイント
ずっと何回も言いますから覚えておいてください
次の言葉を入れたので読み方わからない
美醜 美醜 快不快 苦楽などはものにあたって判断するのはありのままの事実ではありません
このありのままの事実っていうのは
この仏教的な表現ですよ
ありのままに見ましょうと
そこで私たちはこの美しい美しくないとかね
ものにあたって言うんですよ
あなたは美しい あなたはねという風にね
醜いとは言えないんですけどね
そこで快不快とかね このお酒はすごく愉快なと愉快ですよとかね
酒にあたって言うんですよ
だからそれがありのまま事実じゃないので
決してものにあたって言って言うべきじゃないんです
美味しい酒を飲まれて幸せだとかね
だから危険ですよ 酒のおかげで人生は楽しみ
楽しいやと ものにあたって言うと
ブランドの服やらカバンやら身に着けることできるんだから
自分が幸せだという生き方っていうのは
とても危険な 精神的にイカれてしまう生き方なんです
例えば酒のおかげで楽しいという人は
早くも病気になっても廃人になるでしょう
だから幸福はなくなっちゃうんです
例えば賭け事をするのは楽しいよと思っちゃうと
それ人生はダメになっちゃうでしょうに
だから ものにあたって楽しみを解説してはいけないんです
とても危険なことなんです
それまたありのままの事実ではないんですよ
ありのままの事実っていうのは
花見たら自分が楽しがったっていうことなんです
花にあたってはいけないんですよ
花が何も悪いこともいいこともしてないんです
私はなんと美しいという花がヤギいたら何するかというと
パクッと食べるでしょうに
だからヤギにしてみれば
あ なんと美味しいでしょうかと
私にとってはなんて美しいでしょうかと
花が何かやった？何もやってないんですよ
だからものに当たるんじゃないんです
はい えーと 幸不幸 快不快
苦楽は この主観的な認識ですね
個っていうのは個人のね
一人一人の主観的な認識
まあ例えば日本のは 日本はもう納豆美味しいとと思っている
と 外国人は臭いなと 何か美味しいでしょうかと思っちゃうとする
別に納豆何か悪いことしたわけじゃないんです
外国人に対して差別感持ってるわけじゃないんです
それぞれ個人の主観なんです
そういうことで この この幸福
不幸も同じことで この幸不幸
快不快 苦楽っていうのは必ずしも個人の主観であることを覚えておいてください
皆様方は喧嘩することをすごく悪いと思ってるでしょ
で これ幸せと思ってる人々いますよ
喧嘩することを職業にしている人々もいるんですよ
結構金儲かっているんです
喧嘩して 知らないでしょうね
これプロレスラーとボクシングとか
あれ 人ぶん殴ることでしょうに
もう怪我させるでしょうに
ちょっとしたことでもう命も危険になるぐらいでしょうに
あの人々はあれは楽しいだと
幸福だと 思っているんです
だからといって皆様もボブ・サップと喧嘩しようとしちゃうとね
幸福というところじゃないと思いますけど
紙一つまとめるようなぐるぐる巻いて捨てるかもしれませんし
ちょっとだからまあしかしボブ・サップとしてはいろいろ戦うことは
その人の金儲かるの金儲かる手段であって
それで世界的か分かりませんだけど
アメリカと日本ぐらいでも人気者にはなっている
アメリカもどうか分かりませんだけど
日本ではね そういうことだから
幸福っていうのは主観の問題で
個人の問題なんです 喧嘩することも幸福だと思っている人はいるし
ご飯食べることは最高の幸せ
幸福だと思っている人もいるし
ご飯よりも音楽聴くことは幸せだと思っている人もいるし
それはその人はそれぞれ勝手で
はい この事実さえ理解できれば
人生はかなり穏やかになるのです
これ知っておけば結構楽になりますよ
何を知ってるかというと
楽しいのは自分ですということなんです
そこで何で問題になるのかというと
私は例えば唐辛子いっぱいつけてる何か食べ物を食べて
美味しくて美味しくて
これ日本人にはこれすっごく美味しいんですよ
食べてください 食べてくださいと
まあ強引に押し付けるでしょうに
まあそんなやったことないんですけど
これからやりますけど
それで食べた日本人があまりにも辛くて頭がパニック状態になっちゃって
ひどい目に遭うでしょうに
そうするとお互いに仲が悪くなるでしょうね
この人はしつこいなとか
強引だなとかね それでトラブルが起こるんですよ
例えば 親が子供にあなたはあの人と一緒になりなさいとかね
親から見ればすごい可愛くて
まあうちの何て言いますか
お嫁さんとしてはものすごく可愛くて
欲しいなと思っても その肝心の男の子がもう嫌いだったらどうしますかね
まあたまに日本にもそういう現象はあるし
もうアジアだったらかなりあるんですよ
親がどこかの女の子を見たら
もう可愛くて可愛くて
で 娘にしたくなっちゃって
それで自分の息子にその子を押し付けるんです
あの人と結婚しなさいと
その男の子はその女の子
この子嫌いだったらどうしますかね
だから楽しみ 幸福っていうのは個人の主観であるとわかると
こういう強引な態度で他人に押し付けることはしないんですよ
だから例えば逆に教職で
もうもうもう凶暴な人が好き勝手に生活できること自体が自由で自由な生き方やと思ってるアメリカは
その自分たちの凶暴な人のみ生きる権利があるんだぞという生き方が随分強烈に強引に押し付けられてるでしょうね
それで世界はめちゃくちゃでしょうに
日本の経済状態もいつでも危険な危うく状態にあるのは
強引に押し付け方でしょうね
日本人には日本人の経済システム対策ポリシーがあるんですけど
例えば何て言いますか
もう農業とかね 全部自由にしなさいとか何とかとかね
言ったっても それで安い野菜やら米やら手に入るかもしれませんだけど
東京に住んでいる人々には
でも田舎で野菜作って
なんとかそれに生きてる人々とはみんなどうすればいいんです
それから だから そのその国にはそれぞれの生き方あるんですけど
これはもうグローバリゼーションということでできなくなるんですよ
だからグローバリゼーションというのは
世界中みんな仲良くすることだったらいいんですけど
そうではなくて 私たちの安定のために世界は奴隷になれという話なんです
我々は売りたい放題売るんだよ
君たちは買いなさいよと
そうやって一方的に売ることをできれば
我々の経済は安定すると
それ安定するためには世界的にどこでも障害なく物を売れなくちゃいけないんだという一方的な言い方なんです
だから世界はすごい苦しんでるんです
そういうやり方で だからこの真理わかってないんですよ
だからもう人に押し付けるんじゃないんですよ
皆様もインド人に仲良くすることができたら
決してこの生肉とかね
生魚とかね これこそ美味しいんだよと
すごいお金かかってもう用意する必要ないんで
それを強引すぎなんです
向こう食べませんから
だから皆様から見れば
なんで刺身が食べないんですか？これすごく美味しいんでしょうかと
でしょうねと 思っても
インド人から何で生ものを食べるんでしょうかと
すごく鳥肌が立つんですよ
だからこのあまり他人に押し付けない方が世界は平和ですよ
そこで親子の問題もなくなるでしょうに
親は自分の主観を徹底的に子供に押し付ける
それでトラブルが起こるでしょうに
会社でもそうでしょうね
社長とやら もうもう何も世間知らずの連中がものすごい社員にいろんなことを押し付けちゃうと
もう仕事も何もうまくいかなくなっちゃうでしょう
だからやっぱり楽しみのは自分ですと
幸福っていうのは自分個人の主観的なことであると
自分にとって幸福っていうものを
他人にとっては別にわからないんだということを理解しておけば
みんなものすごい あの
柔軟性のある立派な人間になりますよ
頑固さも消えちゃって
ということで このところ大事なポイントは
楽しいのは自分ですということ覚えてほしいんです
で これで楽しいのは自分ですと
テーマの続きですけど
これを忘れたらどうなるでしょうかと
例えば楽しいのは自分ですという真理を忘れたらどうなるんですかと
で 今説明しましたけど
先に はい ものに幸福を
空楽の価値を入れると
人は苦難の海に溺れます
だけど空楽は物にあると
鞄にあると思っちゃうと
お化粧品にあると思っちゃうと
ブランドの服装にあると思っちゃうと
マイホームにあると思っちゃうと
これからもう苦難の海なんですよ
だって いくらあっても足らんでしょ？そういうものは
金だったらいくらあっても足らんでしょうに
美しさだったらいくらあっても足らんでしょうに
ここで戦わなくちゃ得られないでしょうに
友達が高いカバン持ってると
自分はもうもう借金でもしてサラ金にでも手を出して買ったりするでしょうに
だからそういうふうなことでも苦難の海に溺れるんですよ
だから人生は苦しいのは
この我々はものに当たっているんだからなんです
ものは幸福も不幸ももたらしてこないんです
猫を飼ったら楽しい 猫は全然楽しみを与えてないんですよ
これも個人の主観ですよ
猫を見たらまあ可愛い可愛い
なんて可愛いと思う人にとっては楽しいんですよ
だから猫アレルギー人にも猫を飼わせるのは良くないでしょ
ある人は猫はすごく可愛いと思ったって
それは明らかに主観的な楽しみであって
猫は別に何の悪いことも何のいいこともしてないんです
ヘビをペットに飼ってる人もいるでしょうに
ヘビは何もしませんよ
喋ることさえもしない
ただずーっと寝ているだけ
でもヘビが可愛いと思う人にとっては
見ると可愛いし 触ると可愛いし
体でいろいろあっちこっち入れたり
ポケットに入れたり 首にかけたり
いろんなことをしたりして本人が楽しんでる
ヘビは知らん こんなことはもう
だからといって 誰かに家に行ったら
もうヘビ これかわいいですよと
ヘビが嫌い人はもう鳥肌が立って逃げるでしょうね
だから 全てのものにその事実を当てはめます
ヘビと猫の例だけじゃなくて
だからこの我々はこのものは楽しいと思っちゃうと
例えばヘビが可愛いと思ってる人があらゆる珍しいヘビとか買っちゃおう買おうとするでしょうね
すっごいお金それになくなるでしょうね
ペット用のヘビっていうのはそう安くはないんです
トカゲなんかはもうそんなに可愛いと思わないんで
別に でも日本で可愛いと買ってるでしょ
その可愛いとペット用のトカゲってのはえらい高いんです
だからこの物に楽しみがあると思っちゃうと
我々はそれを探さなくちゃいけないし
探すために苦労しなくちゃいけない
それから守らなくちゃいけないし
戦わなくちゃいけないし
大変なことが現れてきます
はい それで物を獲得する
奪い合うという争いが生じる
当然それが生じるんだよ
奪い合いという争いが世界でずっとあることでしょうに
だってこれがなければ私は不幸だと思っちゃうと
それは他人のものだったら奪うでしょうね
はい 次 他人と戦ったり
殺し合いをしたり 戦争したりすることになる
なんで世の中に戦争まであるのかというと
この楽しみのは自分ですということを忘れているんです
物にあると思っているんです
で 北朝鮮人は日本人誘拐することで幸福になると勘違いしているんです
日本にとっては迷惑でしょうし
そういうことで で イラクを潰したらアメリカは平和とそちらは思っている
イラク人にとって迷惑でしょうし
そんなのはアメリカの平和はイラクは壊したわけでもないし
それは自分たちのだらしない生き方だから
もう互いにアメリカの中でどれほど殺し合いやってるのかと
それは全然気にしないんですね
全く平和がないし 安心して歩けないし
これ誰かのせいにする
だからそういう生き方だから
世の中で戦争まで起こるんです
これは完全に間違いなんです
みんなこの 楽しみって何なのかと勉強してないんです
何のために生きてるのかと勉強してないんです
理解してないんです ありのままに見てないんです
だから苦しい世界が現れているんです
はい 次に行きます ですから
楽しいのは自分です またもう一度強調します
楽しみは物のあるのではなく
そのものと触れる自分の心に現れる感情なのです
分かりますね 今はもう難しいことを使っても
楽しみっていうのは物にあるんじゃなくて
そのものに触れると自分の心に現れる感情です
楽しいという感情です
はい それが別の言葉で言えば
ものに対するこのアプローチです
だからあなたは猫を見てどんなアプローチを取るのかっていうことなんです
猫アレルギーがなくても
猫は嫌いだという人もいるし
大好きだという人もいるでしょうに
そして大好きという人が楽しみを感じるし
嫌いと思っている人が嫌な気持ちを不幸を感じるし
猫が何か悪いことをしたわけじゃなくて
その個人のアプローチなんです
はい アプローチが悪ければ
富に溢れても不幸でしょうし
もうわかるでしょう アプローチが悪ければ
もう富に溢れていても
宮殿に住んでいたっても不幸ですよ
いくらお金があっても
アプローチが悪ければ
もう不幸のどん底なんです
もうとっくにもうわかっていると思います
だから決してお金は幸せは運ばないんです
マイホームは幸せを運ばないんです
アプローチがちょっと悪くなっちゃうと
何があってもどうしようもないんです
だって豊かな家族の子供たちなんかも
もう家出するでしょ 麻薬に手を出したりして大変なことになるでしょ
だからもうお金ない 我々から見ればあれほどお金あるんだから
何が不安あるのかと でもその子供に対しては不安ですよ
それが 親が愛情を出してくれないし
ただ金で抑えようとしているし
それが嫌で だったら麻薬でも何でもやって
親まで破壊してやるぞと
親の仕事まで破壊させてやるぞと頑張っちゃうんです
ですから ただ豊かものに溢れたんだからで幸せじゃない
アプローチが変わっちゃうと大変です
次 アプローチが良ければ少々の豊かさでも幸福になる
だからたくさんなくても
アプローチが良ければもう幸せなんです
本当はすごく楽しく生活しているホームレスもいますよ
すごく穏やかで楽しくて
で またなんで私がホームレスになったのかと
すごい違うアプローチで不幸を感じる人もいるし
あ これでいいやと 別になんの不安もないんだと
何の問題もなくて もう何とか食べればいいんじゃないかなと
病気になってしまって別にいいんじゃないか
それで まあそれで死んじゃってもということ
で アプローチ変えればその人生が幸せになっちゃうんです
ですから このものに対する個人のアプローチ
というわけで ダイヤがあれば
どんな人でも必ず幸せっていうことは成り立たない嘘です
ある人はそれですごい幸福を感じるかもしれませんし
ある人はそう感じないかもしれません
はい で これであのお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
これはサンユッタニカーヤの番目のテキストのページにあります
ナテーカーマヤーニチッターニローケーサンカッパラゴープリサッサカーモーティッタンテチッターニタテーワローケーアテッタディーラウィナヤンティチャンダ
仏教はこの俗世間で楽しんで生きていなさいという話ではないんだから
今日は言っているのは俗世間の話で
だから結論なし 話今日終わるんです
で まあこういう場合はブッダの直接の言葉だから
ブッダが言いたいことは言ってます
ネテーカーマヤーニチッターニローケー
この訳できないチッターっていうのは
このいろいろということで
世の中を見るともういろいろですよ
人間見てもいろいろでしょうね
家で言えば 例えばデパートの女性の服の売り場に行けば
まああるわあるわあるわ
もういろいろでしょうに
どれほどあるかとも 私たちは男たちでも何か品物をいくつかしかないのに
それにも選ぶに苦労しますでしょ
これもいいんだけど これもいいんだけど
女性ってどれぐらい苦労しているんでしょうかね
私たちは 10個ぐらいの品物で選択に苦しんでいるのに
これ 1000個  2000個ぐらいの品物の間で幸せでしょうかね
わからないんですけど
男は文句言うだけで 女が買い物に行ったらもう 1 日中店から追い出すまで出て行かない
出てこないんだと やっぱり苦労しているんです
選択に だからチッターニっていうのは
そうやっていろいろ様々美しいということですね
ネテカーマ それらは人間の欲ではありませんと
欲っていうのは即席の態度で言うんですよ
楽しみではありませんと
この服いろいろあるとかね
人間いろいろいるとか
食べ物いろいろあるとかね
それが幸福でも楽しみでも何でもありませんと
サンカッパラゴプリサッサカーモ
それについてサンカッパ
自分の考え方 自分のコンセプト
概念が欲ですよ ですから
この比較的動物の世界であるでしょうに
チンパンジーとかね チンパンジーのオスだったらチンパンジーのメスに恋した方がいいでしょ
で チンパンジーを人間がずっと赤ちゃんの時買ってあげたりすると
もしあの あの あの人 何て言いますか
面倒見る人は あの飼育係の人はもう可愛い女の子だったら
そのオスがその女の子に恋するでしょう
これ決してありえないというか
もうもう実らない恋なんですけど
でもチンパンジーがその女の子しか見てないんだから
年頃になってくると その飼育係の女の子に恋しちゃう
そしてそちらはもう科学的に飼育しているんだから
年頃になってくると別なメスのチンパンジーを入れてあげるでしょうね
じゃあ交尾でもして子供でも作ってくださいと
逃げるんです 逃げ回る
なかなか仲良くしない
脅したりする 嫌がらせまでする
だから普通常識で考えれば
チンパンジーのオスはチンパンジーのメスに恋するのは普通なんですけど
やっぱりやっぱりこの欲というのは
そうやって物にあるものじゃなくて
その個人がどう考えるかっていうことなんです
だからチンパンジーは人間に恋するの別に不思議でも何でもないんです
これ同じく人間も動物に恋するかもしれませんよ
逆に人間いるの人間は嫌だと
それは大体あり得るんです
それから 例えば野菜とかね
野菜によりますけど 料理して食べた方が美味しいと
ある人は思うんだけど
生で食った方が美味しいと
また ある人は思う ジャガイモなんか必ずもうね
何か料理して食べるでしょ
でも生でも美味しいんですよ
だからそんなに味の問題はないんです
ですから この自分がどう思うのかっていうことなんです
だから仏教というのは
この世の中にある様々なものを
すごい美しいもの いろいろあるんですが
それがよくそれがいいこと言うなよと
それがよくじゃないんです
自分のアプローチが欲ですよと
それでティッタンテチットラニタテワロケ
この世の中の様々な美しいものは
チットラティッハニ そのままあるだけですと
何も悪いこともいいこともしないで
そのままあるだけで だからデパートにあるいろんな高価な服なんかは
何も悪いことしてないんで
人を見て誘惑しているわけないんですよ
私を買って買ってとかね
全然言わないんです 置いたまんまでただの品物でしょ
でもそれを見た私の心で
あるいは女性の心で いきなり気持ちが変わっちゃって
欲しい欲しいということ
欲が生まれてくるんです
だから美しいものはそのまんまにあるだけだと
アテットディラウィニアンティチャンダン
しかし この場合はディラ
賢者はチャンダン 心の中にあるアプローチをコントロールすると
それが仏教いう解脱の世界なんですね
だから依存しないと自由になるんだぞと
ものにバカにされませんよと
ことで 心にある欲しいとアプローチを消す
それで自由になるって
それは仏教で言ってる
悟りの境地を言ってますけど
はい いい加減な日本訳はしましたけどね
家にある様々な美しいものは欲ではない
人の考えが欲なのです
様々なものは世にそのようにあるだけなので
知恵のある人は心にある意欲を捨てるのです
ちょっとややこしいんですけど
様々なものは世にそのそのままあるだけ
我々に話しかけてるわけじゃないんです
動物園に行って何かパンダ見るとパンダがこちらに話しかけてるわけじゃないんです
パンダは自分勝手でゴロゴロしながら笹のなんとか食べながらいるだけで
で見ると こちらの心に何か気持ちが変わるんです
だから賢者はその心の中に現れる気持ちを改良するんです
はい 次に行きます これで 第3章に入ります
えーと かなりテーマがいろいろ変わりますからね
楽しみが生じる過程ということに
だからどのようにね 我々は欲やらね
楽しみやら幸福というような気持ちをね
どういうふうに心の中で作るんでしょうかという
その過程なんですね それそれしか勉強するものはないんです
はい それから仏教の話で
自分というのはこの内とないと書いてましたけどね
アッジャッタというパーリ語で
で 個人のこの構成 我々は自分自分と何とか偉そうなことを言うんですけど
仏教はこういう 6つに分析するんですね
1番目はチャック 目ですね
2番目は耳ですね  3番目はガーナ
と何でしたっけ？鼻ですね
それから舌ですね それから体ですね
それからマナ 心ですね
そういう 6つがあるんですよ
この体の中で それで体ができているんです
自分がそれで構成しているんです
チャックソティウハカエマナという
それで外の世界は花があるんだ
家があるんだ 建物あるんだというふうに我々無知な人は思うんだけど
仏教はそう言わないんですよ
外の世界は我々を目を通してあると知ってるんですよ
目を通すと目に入るのは色と形なんですね
それはパーリ語でルーパと言うんです
目には決して建物は入りませんよ
あまりにも小さいんだから
目は 色と形だけは入ります
それから耳に音は入るんです
で 舌 鼻には香りというもの入るし
舌に味というものは入るし
体にはいろんなものを触れるんです
それもすごい小さいものですよ
例えばこのビルを体に触れませんよ
体で感じることできないんです
遠くから見ることはできますけど
40階もあるんだぞと言ったって見えるわけじゃないんですよ
ただエレベーターの数字だけなんです
見た人います？見えません
それはエレベーターの数字だけです
だから実際我々の体に入るものはそうやって随分制限されているんです
で 舌に入るのは味であって
それも味は幾つかと決まってるし
体に触れるものは一応硬いとかね
温かいとかね それぐらいのもので
これパーリ語でポッダッバというんですね
それで法っていうのは心に入るもの
法っていうのも何でもって意味なんですね
場合によって変わります
仏教ではいつでもで だいたいこの場合は何でもって意味なんです
心にはもう何でも入りますよ
心では何でも考えられますから
もうアイデアなど全て
そこで私は何を言いたいんでしょうかというと
私私と言っても こういう風にこの 6つのチャンネルがあります
この 6つのチャンネルにしつこいな情報入るんですよ
その入る情報はこの 6つなんです
外界は それがごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ合成するんです
はい 次に行きます まあそれからこの説明ですね
外と触れて認識が生じる
外といってあの 6つですよ
それに触れて認識が生まれるんですね
目に光の情報が だから目だけ例にします
目に光の情報が触れる
そうすると目がそれを受ける
感じる それはパーリ語でエーダナーって言うんですよ
光が入ったなと目は感じるんです
反応するんです 目は 目は反応したら感じたものを認識する
だから決して我々は外にある桜の花は見えませんよ
そちらにある光の情報
目に触れると この触れたところだけに反応して認識するんです
だから実際に外にある桜を見た人はいません
自分の中で起きた反応を認識しているだけなんです
感じたものを認識する
認識に合わせて欲 怒り
喜び 悲しみなどが生じる
だから桜の花を見る 또もう何が感情が生じるか分かったもんじゃないんですよ
人はそれぞれ違うんです
だから一般的に言ってはならない
桜の花見たら楽しいでしょうとかね
私が楽しいと言ってもいいんだけど
他の人は わからないんです
それぞれ違うんです お互いに楽しいと言うんですけど
その楽しみが違うんですよ
皆様はもし子供の頃 小さい頃
1歳  2歳頃のことを思い出すならば
視覚っていうのはすごい違うとわかりますよ
一番小さい時の視覚はすごく違うんです
大人になってくるとそれまた感覚が変わるんです
だから小さな子供はすごく綺麗可愛いと思うものは
我々大人はそう思わないでしょう
子供にとってはものすごい別世界に見えるんです
時々石一個でも拾って随分大事にする
宝物にするでしょう それで大人から見れば
まあ子供だからっていうふうな気持ちになるんだけど
そうじゃないんですよ
子供にとってはあれは本気で宝物なんです
見るとむちゃくちゃ感動するんですよ
だからその視覚は大人になってくると変わっていくんです
ですから この認識に合わせて感情っていうのは生まれてくる
何かちょっとしたガラクタを見たら
子供がもう全身で感動したりするし
我々は全然感動したりはしないし
あるものを見たら ある人は笑っちゃうし
ある人は怒っちゃうし
同じものなのに 時々子供の声を聞いて
ああ可愛いなと思う人もいて
うるさいなと思う人もいるでしょう
同じ声 ですから それがこの声
耳に入って入った感覚を処理するんです
頭の中である人の耳にはちょっと感情
感覚がちょっとおかしかったんです
だからうるさいとなったんです
ある人の耳ではそうではなくて
穏やかな感覚になったんです
だからなんて子供かわいいなと思っちゃうんです
だから ここ 自分の肉体がどのように情報を受け取っているかということによって
幸福っていうのはもう決めてしまうんですよ
なんか本当につまらないんですよ
そういうこと だから結局は美しい音楽とか存在しないんですよ
そのその音が自分の耳でもうガチャガチャガチャガチャ嫌な観測するんだったらうるさいんです
音楽じゃないんです うるさい音でも耳で穏やかな気分を作ると美しい音楽なんです
耳次第です 音楽次第じゃないんです
はい したがって 同じものを見ても
人それぞれ別々な感情を引き起こす
同じ映画を見ても 人はそれぞれ違うんです
主観的な判断には過去の思い
知識 習性などが影響を与える
それで頭で処理する時も
我々はあるのままにはやらないんですよ
あらゆるバイアスをかけるんです
そういうバイアスというのは
過去の思い 犬に噛まれたことがあったら
いくら可愛い犬 いくら本当に行儀のいい
言うことをよく聞いて
聞いていろいろ遊びができる犬に出会っても
嫌な気持ちがするんです
それからこの知識も同じでしょうし
つまらない絵画とか みんなすごい喜んで見ているでしょうね
あれがいろいろパンフレットを読み
読んで読んで読んで 強引に綺麗だと叩き込むんです
で 習性もありますよ 人間にないと思っても
人間にもあります 人間の場合
習性っていうのは 例えば小さい時から毎回すごくいつでも気分が機嫌が悪くて
もう何でも批判したりする習性がついちゃうと
いつでもその性格になってしまうんです
いつでも見栄張り習性ついちゃうと
それで物事を見えなくなって
それで判断しちゃうんです
また 先に引き起こした感情も影響する
これが説明しないとわからないんです
例えば必ずしも 例えば自分がバラの花が好きとします
だからと私はバラの花を見るたびに必ずしも気持ちよくなるわけじゃないんですよ
前の感情も影響を与えるんです
例えば 外でもの散々人と喧嘩しました
ものすごい嫌な気持ちになりました
それで部屋に入ったら綺麗なバラの花がある
はぁ綺麗だと思わない
その時は 見えているのに
なぜかというと その時の判断は前の感情で影響を与えて
そのバイアスがかかったんです
[背景音楽]だからもう会社で随分なんか機嫌がよく
楽しく仕事をして家に帰ると
いきなり奥さんがいきなり怒鳴りつけちゃって
あんた先生 家のことは見ようともしないんだから
まあ今日はこういうこと子供をやったんではなくて
ああそう どういうことでしょう
すごく穏やかでアプローチするんです
じゃあ落ち着いてから調べて聞いてみましょうとかね
で それで同じ人がまた会社で散々いじめられたり
仕事がうまくいかなくて
すごい惨めな気持ちで家に帰ると同じこと言われるとどんなことになるかといって
いきなり怒るんです おい
何言うんです 私は忙しいんだ
仕事でやって疲れてくると
そんなこと言ったって無駄とかね
今の面倒を見るのはお前の仕事ではないかと
子供が悪くなったのはお前のせいではないかというと
もうそういうことを言うんです
人間の生き方はそういうことなんですよ
同じことに出会っても
ちょっと前の感情で次の判断が決めてしまう
どちらでも当てにならんですよ
もう結局は で これは全てまとめて先入観と称しましょうと
だいたいこの先入観ですね
我々は花見ても先入観で見る
音を聞いても先入観で聞く
ご飯食べても先入観で食べる
だから日本人には刺身はおいしいし
インド人にはおいしくない
ということになるんです
誰もありのままに見たことはないんです
すごい先入観の塊で我々は生きているんです
そういうことだから そう簡単には幸福にならないんですよ
はい えーと まあ今日は早く終わりにしましょう
えーと まあ眼耳鼻舌身というね
目耳鼻などの場合もプロセスは同じで
だから今説明したのは目の説明でしたけど
耳の鼻で何であろうとも同じプロセスなんです
先入観で見ちゃうんです
胃の働きの場合も 自分だけの考えが流れるのです
それからちょっと違うのは意なんですよ
意識なんです 人間っていうのは本を読んで楽しむ
考えて楽しむ 将棋とかゲームやって楽しむ
その場合はこの体で楽しむことじゃなくて
頭で楽しむんですよ それも個人個人で違うんですよ
自分の考え方というのは勝手に流れてるんで
これなかなか変えられません
妄想の流れは この変えようと思ってみんな小説とか読んだりするでしょうに
なんで小説読んで楽しむかというと
あの考え方をなんとか強引に変えたいんです
その時でも やっぱり気に入ってる小説を選んで読むんですよ
だから 元の考え方に合うようなものを選んで読んだりする
だから まあそちらでも一応プロセスは決まっている
先入観というプロセスは決まっている
考え方にも激しく先入観入ってます
楽しいか否かはそのものの問題ではなく
ものに触れ 個人の認識が決めるのですということで
何回も言っていることなんです
だから我々の心の中にある
先入観が神様みたいな感じでお前苦しめ
お前楽しめとその都度その都度決めてくれるんです
だから先入観だからなかなか自由がないんですよ
例えば会社でもいじめられて散々失敗して
ものすごい嫌な気分になったところで
奥さんももういきなりもうキャーキャーと言ってくるというのは
この場合はニコニコとやってやるぞとはできないんですよ
会社は会社 家は家やと割り切っていることできないんです
そこで会社で馬鹿にされちゃって
お前こんな調子だったらもうクビにするぞとかなんとか脅しまでしたところで
家に帰ったら子供をパパと言って自分のことを飛んでくると
もうその場で家は会社は会社
家は家 子供は子供やってて割り切っちゃって
ああ 君可愛いです こんな可愛い可愛いとかね
そういう風に素直には喜べないんです
あっち行けと その時言うんです
もし割り切ることができればね
ありがたいんですけど
瞬間瞬間に やっぱりこの先入観が邪魔するんです
はい そこで生命 命 自分って何なのかと
生きるということは何なのかというと
認識が起こることで生きている自分がいるという実感が現れる
皆様方は我々に魂があるんだ
霊魂があるんだ 神様がなんとか何とかそういう考え方はあまり意味がないんです
我々には見えているんだから生きているんだぞと実感があるんですよ
音を聞かれて聞こえているんだから生きているんだという実感があるんですよ
体を触っちゃうと感じるでしょ
だから生きているんだという実感があるんです
生きているというか そんなもんですよ
すごい単純です 何のことないんです
そんな単純ですからね
だから幸福か不幸か その認識で決められる
だから目で見えるわ 耳で聞こえるわ
舌で味わえるわ 鼻で香りを嗅ぐわ
体で寒いから暖かいやら硬いとかね
感じるわ それで頭でゴチャゴチャ考えているわ
それだけのことで幸福か不幸かってのを決めるんです
この認識のことで だから自分がどう認識するかっていうことぐらいのことなんですよ
自分次第です もの次第じゃないんです
自分がちゃんと割り切って
パチパチと割り切ってアプローチすればもう幸せですよ
色声などなどの外の情報に触れることで生きる実感が起こるので
やむを得ず人は物に依存する
執着する そこで人間が失敗するんですよ
本当は私が言った通りに割り切っちゃえばよかったのに
失敗する 君のおかげで私は幸せやと思っちゃうでしょう
あれ間違いでしょうに
そこで君に依存しちゃうんですね
これの会社のおかげで私は幸せ
会社に依存するんです
執着するんです 家庭にお金に服に
これのおかげやと そうじゃないんですよ
自分の心の中のアプローチなんですよ
それはすごい 例えば我々一般的なおかげさまで幸せで生きてるんだと言うでしょうね
おかげさまでというとたん
外の世界のことを気にするでしょ
違うんです おかげさまで生きているわけじゃないんです
この世の中 いいでも悪いでもなんでもないんです
自分のアプローチなんです
自分が良いアプローチを作っていると
おかげさまで幸せだということを言えるんです
だからアプローチさえ変えれば
どんなに大変にでもおかげさまで幸せだということは言えるんです
その代わりに我々が何をするかというと
あのものにかかっちゃうんですよ
噛みつくんです それ執着ということなんです
ものに噛みついちゃっても何の意味もないんです
これだから幸せやとものに我々はあまりもしがみつく
これは完全に間違いだとお釈迦様はおっしゃるんですよ
違うんだよと 家に執着するなよと
こんな噛み付いたっても
それが幸せを運んでくれるんじゃないんだよと
心にあるアプローチが問題ですよ
そこで仏教で有名な執着の話にはなります
はい 早く進みましょう
今日テーマはここからなんですけど
それは早く飛ばします
今まで序論でしたけど
自分を生かしてくれる目耳などにも執着する
それで終わらないんですよ
生きてるんだという実感が
目やら耳やら作ってくれるでしょうね
だから体にも執着する
すごく執着する 外の世界にも執着する
我が身にも徹底的に執着する
しかし 自由自在に幸福を感じられるように主観を改良することはこれでできなくなる
こんなとんでもない失敗するんだから
淡々と割り切ってアプローチ変えて
すごい自由に思うがままに幸福を作ることはできなくなっちゃうんです
本当はご飯としておにぎり 1個あっても
フランス料理あってもどうでもいいんですよ
おにぎり 1個だったら
そこでアプローチ変えれば
ものすごいごちそうで味わって楽しめますよ
でも人はなんだ おにぎり 1個か今日はと
なんで不幸かということでアップするんだから不幸を感じるんです
フランス料理を食べなきゃ幸せを感じないというバカが
もうお金貯めてお金貯めて
月1回ぐらいは行って食べなくちゃいけない羽目になるんです
本当は毎日楽しいはずなのに
毎日ご飯食べてるんだから
それができなくなるんで
だから自由自在に幸福を感じることは
この執着のせいでできなくなるんです
体と心の感情がすべてを支配することになる
だからそこからこの逆に心の中に先入観やら感情があるでしょ
あんなへんてこりんな感情が
フランス料理を食べれば幸せやと
そういう先入観があるんです
お茶漬けは幸せじゃない
あまりにも貧しい食べ物
と思っちゃうと フランス料理は月1回と
それでもないぐらいで
お茶漬けはほぼ毎日のようになってくると
どれほど不幸かと思いますかね
その人は かわいそうでしょう
だからってその人に毎日フランス料理食べられます？食べられないでしょうに
だからこの主観の自分をもう管理しちゃうんですね
あのへんてこりな主観も先入観も
えーと 支配するんですね
よって楽しみに制限がつく
だから制限付きの楽しみ
フランス料理は食べれば幸せやと思う人にとっては
1ヶ月間に 1ヶ月間 1回ということになるんです
それでもうきれいに制限になっちゃったんです
外国旅行こそ楽しいやと思っちゃうと
もう 1年に1回できれば最高ですけどね
それもできんでしょ ということで
簡単に楽しみがもうもう 1万1億分の1に減ってしまうんです
本当は瞬間瞬間楽しんで生きていられます
消えちゃうんです はい
で 楽しみの制限 人の目の力は決まっている
それも徐々に衰えていく
それで我々体として楽しむでしょ
それで目っていうのは肉体だから
目にはもう目の力っていうのはもう決まってますよ
すぐわかります そんなの
色はどれぐらい認識するかとかね
視力がどれぐらいあるのかとかね
それから何て言いますか
このスタミナがね どれぐらい目にあるのかとかね
決まってますから だから目がもともと弱いんだったら
もう早くも目が見えなくなるでしょう
目の後ろにあるなんとか膜がありますね
なんて言いますか あれは
網膜 であれを力が大体決まって
あれ弱い人は早くも目が病気になっちゃうんです
だから 目を通してどれぐらい楽しめるのかということは
この肉体を持った時点でもう制限されているんです
それから そんなある力を持って生まれても
徐々に減っていくんです
毎日目を使えば使うほど視力は減るんです
視力ではなくて 何て言いますか
目の力が減っていくんです
回数券みたいなものです
それ耳も全部同じなんです
はい 業によって五道の能力と寿命が決まっている
あの業っていうのは この過去の業ですね
こちらで肉体を持って生まれたら
この肉体を持って生を作ったっていうのは過去の業のエネルギーなんですよ
そこで目の力どれぐらい
目の寿命どれぐらい 耳の力どれぐらいとかね
その瞬間で決めてるんです
だからどんな音楽好きになるかっていうことは
もう生まれる時もう決まってるぐらいなもんです
そこでどれぐらいの量を聞くかっていうね
だからよく若者はこのすごい音でヘッドフォンで音楽とか聴くとどうなるんですか？わかってるでしょ
目が遠くなっちゃうでしょ
なぜかって 一生の使うべき回数券を
年で使ってるんです で
回数券終わっちゃったんです
こう耳がもう機能低下するんです
目も同じです であの目の場合は
まあ一応自然の流れもありまして
このあれもこれも何だかんだも身を滅したっても
この時間的な関係もありますから
まあそれほどは見えることはできないんですね
だから目の後は結構残りますが
その代わりに目そのものが弱くなるんです
だから見て見て見て見て見すぎて見えなくなったっていうことはそれほどないんです
それだったら激しく この色がものすごい激しく変わるものは
ずっと見続けなきゃあまり誰もそれをしません
なぜかというと めまいがしたり
吐き気が出たりして倒れちゃいます
だからこの自然で 例えば音をたくさん聴くと耳が遠くなるのは当たり前ですけど
たくさんものを見て目が見えなくなるということはほとんどケースはない
しかし その代わりに業はすごくずるいんですよ
目そのものを弱くしてくれるんです
だから白内障になったり
緑内障になったり 網膜剥離になったり
いろいろ それで業によって五門も決めます
五門の寿命も決めます
時々人がいるでしょ この歳までいるんだけど
歳で目が見えなくなるとかね
歳まで生きてるんですけど
歳からは耳が聞こえなくなる
聞こえなくなるとかね
それぞれ部品の寿命が決まってますから
それの回数券終わったらもう機能しないんです
だから体に依存して楽しむと思っても
もう生まれた時点でもう制限しているんです
生まれた時点で はい 意識はほぼ自動回転ですから
変えるのは難しい それでみんなすごく苦労するのはこの妄想なんですよ
くだらないことを暗いことずっと考え続ける
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬 なんか頭に入り込んじゃうと
癌みたいにもう何十年もその苦しみで考え続けるでしょ
あれはほとんど自動回転なんです
だから管理できないんです
あの小さい時も何かコンプレックスが入っちゃって
自分が何とか何とかとかね
思っちゃうと もうずっとその精神病気で一生いるはめになるんです
そんなことない いい加減考え方変えなさいと言っても
もう変えることはできないんです
あの 例えば精神病気の場合は
あのケースで言えば みんな私の悪口言ってるんだぞとかいう病気あるでしょう
それで大体女性にありますけど
そういう人々はもう隠れるんですよ
部屋に 外へ出ていかない
どうしても嫌ですって
みんな私の悪口言ってるんだと
で そういう気持ちが過去の業かもしれませんだけど
一旦そういう思考が現れちゃうと
自動回転でもう いくらお医者さんが顔にしてもなかなか大変ですよ
治るのは だからこの五根はもうわかりますけどね
目耳鼻のことはね 心の場合もそういうふうに我々はかなりハメハメられています
だから私は言いたいの
楽しみはものすごい極端にリミットされているんです
はい したがって思い存分には楽しめないのです
だからブッダの教えを理解しない限りはね
思い存分楽しめないんです
で こういう羽目になってるんです
全部解決方法ありますよ
例えば目で物を欲張って見る見るだけじゃなくて
目を活性化する善行をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
音を聞いて聞いて聞いて耳をもう壊すんじゃなくて
耳をリジュアネレーションと英語で言うんですけど
何て言いますか 復活する
善行もしなくちゃいけない
知らないでしょうに 私たちは知ってますよ
お釈迦様の教え知ってるんだから
だからまあそう簡単には耳は遠くならないし
目が見えなくなることもないし
糖尿病になってひどい苦労をすることもないんです
だから体が生まれつき親からもらうもんだから
生まれつきいろいろ病もあるかもしれませんだけど
そんなに病弱でもう倒れるっていうことは
ちゃんとブッダの教えを守って生きる人にはないんです
回数券は全部使いまくることはしないんです
まあ例えば まあ自分が目で見て楽しいならば
欲のない楽しみを作って目で見て
例えば仏像を見るは仏画を見るはとかね
で 場所場所を綺麗にするとかね
それで人々にもしてあげる
人々にも目が楽しくなるように
他人にもその環境を作ってあげる
それで自分が善行したことになる
それは目の働きになるんです
耳の場合でも 他人に聞き心地が良い役に立つ言葉か喋ったりとかね
人を喧嘩してるところでお前らなんで喧嘩するのかではなくて
穏やかな言葉でいろいろ落ち着いてあげたりして
和ませるように自分の声を使う
それで相手の耳が穏やかな気持ちになるでしょう
その徳が自分に返ってくるんです
体の場合でも 自分の体力も
人々のために みんなのためにお布施をする
そうすると自分の体は元気に
回数券は減るんですけど
同時に増えてるんです
だから大丈夫です 本当にお釈迦様が推奨している生き方をするならば
死ぬまですごく知識がピンピンで元気でいられます
で すごい真剣にこの仏教を修行する
在家の方々は何人か知っていた人々がいて
ものすごく厳密に戒律をちゃんと守っているわ
すごく落ち着いて生活するわ
欲に溺れることはないとかね
歳になってももう眼鏡もかけないで
私も眼鏡かけてるでしょうね
本を読むわ ちょっと食べただけでもすぐ聞こえるわ
もう元気ですよ それで突然倒れて二日で死ぬ
倒れたら本人知ってます
終わりだと それで子供たち
孫たちにもいろいろ言って
君たちもしっかりしなさいよと言って
本人が死ぬんです だから本当にその道でやってみると
回数券は毎日毎日減ってはいくんだけど
同時に本人もまだまだまだまだもう溜めているんだからね
そういう生き方ありますよ
このこれはもう全く悲観的な生き方じゃないんです
この業の問題はね と はい
次に行きます 楽しみの正見ですね
心の欲がありすぎると体を使いすぎる
今説明したものですよ
心に先入観があって遊びたいよ
遊びたいってことで体使いすぎるでしょうね
食べすぎるは遊びすぎるは
それで体が壊れるんです
で 正義になります はい
もっと欲しいのに体が先に壊れる
例えばこのエイズやらいろいろ病気もあるでしょうに
若い人がもう体がもうもうものすごく無批判で使ってしまって
楽しみたい 楽しみたい
そこでエイズみたいな病気にかかっちゃうと
薬も何もないでしょうね
それで五 六年で死んじゃうでしょうに
そこから体の使い方間違ってるんです
だからそうでなくても
我々でももう体は余計に使っているんだから
もっといろんな音楽を聞きたいのに
もう聞こえない 聴き覚えではいるんだけど
喜びを感じなくなる 綺麗なものを見たいんだけど
もう目があまり動かない
もう何て言いますか もうあれは
もう 目がはっきり混乱する状態
何て言いますか えっ？その病気がありますけど
何と言いますか 目の視力の乱視
もうどんどん乱視状態激しくなってくると
もう見えないんだからね
絵画買っていたっても
絵画がぐちゃぐちゃになって見えると
もういますよ 乱視状態は決して眼鏡で調整できないほどになるとかね
だからまあそういう風に
まあだからそういう人も見たいという気分があるんですよ
でも先に体が壊れる だからどんな人間でも
もっともっと楽しかったのにという不満で死ぬんです
そんなのは決まってますよ
はい 体に触れるものではなく
別なものを心が楽しみだと判断したく期待すると
食べても美味しくない現象が現れる
これわからないこと書いたんですけど
説明すると簡単なんです
時々我々の頭が先入観が
変なことを考えるんですよ
自分が生きている環境から楽しめなくちゃいけないでしょうに
でもそれ嫌やと思っちゃうんです
結婚しているのに 別な女と一緒になった方がもっと良かったんではないかとかね
別な価値観作っちゃうんですよ
自分に子供がいるのに
もっと男の子でしたからよかった女の子が生まれたらよかったではないかとかね
もっと静かな子供だったらよかったではないかとか
別な価値観を作っちゃうんですよ
そうしちゃうと大変なんです
いくらあってももう機嫌が悪いんです
結婚していたっても喜び感じないんです
別の人と結婚したかったらよかったなとかね
そういう人は子供で殺しちゃうんですよ
それ言ってるんです 頭の中で決めますから
楽しいかないかということは
それで頭勝手にその基準変えちゃうと
例えば皆様日本人でしょう
突然アメリカ人になったら本当に幸せだなと思っちゃうと
どうなるんですかね なれるんですかね
それで日本にいることは嫌で嫌で
不幸になっちゃうんです
基準変えちゃうと それでなんとかしてアメリカに行ったっても
日本人は日本人だからね
それでアメリカ人と一緒になれないんだから
それで別な枠を作って日本人の中のグループの中に生活しなくちゃ
結局同じ羽目になっちゃうんです
だからこの頭の基準 突然変わるんですよ
突然ではなくて それにも原因がありますけど
それでも食べても美味しくないと
ということは この 例えば日本人がアメリカ人になりたくなったならば
日本にいても楽しくない
私が言うのは もうこの環境で死ぬまでいなくちゃあかんでしょうに
その色で その形で一生生活しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だからその基準を大事にしないと
そういうことを起こって楽しみが制限になるんです
はい 同じものを付きまとうと刺激がなくなる
楽しみも消える これもありますよ
なんかずっと同じ環境でいると
ずっと刺激 何でも同じものでしょうに
どんどん同じものの連続だから
また面白くなくなっちゃうんです
だから毎日同じご飯食べられないでしょうに
すごく嫌になるでしょうに
そういう制限もあります
毎回同じ音楽を聴くことできないでしょ
嫌になるんです だからその制限も体に依存するとあります
早く進みましょう もう時間ない
体が衰えて壊れるようになっているから
たとえ楽しみがあっても
その喜びが 喜びも減ってつまらなくなることは確実
それで体っていうのは衰えて壊れるものなんですよ
だから当然我々の楽しみもどんどん減ってなくなるプロセスになってるんです
体に触れるものも簡単に
それだけじゃない 自分が楽しいと思って買った花も簡単に壊れるでしょうに
簡単に壊れる なくなるものだから
喜びが消える前に楽しみの対象が消えることもある
でしょ もっと楽しみかった
楽しみかったのに 例えば誰かが
人が家に来た すっごく楽しかったんです
その人忙しくて 10 分で帰るんです
その時 向こう対象が早く消えたでしょうね
あーもっと楽しく 楽しく
楽しみかったのにとかね
ということなんです すっごい自分の好物があるんですよ
でもほんのちょっとしかないんです
足らない 食べて楽しいんだけど
もっと食べたかったと
そういうことで この対象も簡単に消えてしまいます
人の妄想も管理できないから
それによっても楽しみが消えていく
人がくだらんことを妄想し始めると管理できなくなっちゃうんですね
それで人生を楽しめなくなっちゃうんですね
はい 次に行きます 説明する時間がないんです
えー眼耳鼻舌身っていうのは前の五門ですね
によって入る これ方法じゃない
情報ですね  方法ですか
情報です そこで我々は目耳鼻媒介として楽しむことしかできないでしょうね
でも 目耳鼻に入る情報っていうのはほんの僅かなんですよ
だから目があるんだから思い存分楽しめない
耳があるんだからこそ思い存分楽しめないという
とんでもないことを起きているんです
すでに どんな音も聞こえないでしょうに
どんな色も見えないでしょうに
情報が制限しています
判断する人の主観のフィルターによっても制限される
だから判断する先入観というすごいフィルターがあるでしょ
そいつが決めるんだから
楽しいかないかということは
だから美味しいご飯を食べても
自分の先入観がまずいと判断しちゃうとまずいんです
そこでまた制限される
この主観のフィルターは
また業 知識 習性 経験 妄想
感情などで制限される
このフィルター自体もさらに制限されて硬くなってます
頭の中の先入観のフィルターも
だから心は素直に喜べないのです
だから我々には物に依存すると素直に喜べないんです
まあここは厳密な論理で今言ってますからね
あまり一般的な話にはならないかもしれません
心の中に先入観という大きなフィルターが
鉄の壁があるんです だから素直に喜べない
この鉄の壁からなんとか楽しみを引っ張らないと
結構苦労するんですよ
その鉄の壁っていうのは
業やら経験やら知識やら感情やら
そういうもので作っているんです
それまた毎日硬くなるんですよ
減るんじゃないんです
人間が生きれば生きるほど
先入観がどんどん増えるんであって
減るんじゃないんです
仏教は先入観は綺麗に取りなさいという修行方法なんです
はい で その主観の弱点もあります
楽しみに不満を感じる
楽しみは主観なんですけど
楽しみのはあなたですということは真理なんですけど
でも不満感じるんですよ
感じるのは当たり前だから
このすごい壁を通して楽しむなくちゃいけないんだからね
それでもっと楽しみたくなるんですよ
例えば何かご飯を食べて美味しいなと思っても
なんか不満感じるんですよ
そうするともっと美味しいものを食べたいという気持ちになるんです
これは塩水を飲んでいるようなことで
渇き状態のみが進む だから楽しみたいという渇き状態があるんですよ
それで楽しめば楽しむほど渇き状態が進むだけ
満足しないんです これもこの肉体に依存して楽しむ時の必ずともある問題なんです
仏教ではこれを塩水飲むということに言うんですよ
満足する以前 死を迎える
これで悪いことに なんとか満足しようと必死なんですよ
それにつれ先に死ぬんです
やりたいこといっぱいあったのに
先に死ぬんです はい で終わり
で 結論がないんですけど
今日は とにかく今日は説明したのは
この体に物に依存する世界
それはお釈迦様の智慧から分析したんです
では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました